a plea from the terminator do not
believe your dictator yeah the
kindergarten cop asks russia to stop and
what might be his best work since true
lies arnold schwarzenegger has released
an emotional nine-minute video
addressing the people of russia it's
powerful persuasive and polite which
matters in its attempt to give the basic
facts about vlad putin's invasion of
ukraine
i'm speaking to you today because there
are things that are going on in the
world that have been kept from you
terrible things that you should know
about the world has turned against
russia because of its actions in ukraine
the destruction that russian bombs are
raining down upon innocent civilians has
so outraged the world that the strongest
global economic sanctions ever taken
have been imposed on your country this
is not the war to defend russia did your
grandfather so your great grandfather's
fought this is an illegal war
so yeah very heartfelt and honest he
even talked about his father being a
nazi wow him too
[Laughter]
sorry dad
last name's gutfeld he's pissed all
right
while addressing the russian
government's claims that its troops were
part of the de-nazification of ukraine
he was injured at leningrad that the
nazi army that he was part of did
vicious harm to the great city and to
its brave people when my father arrived
in leningrad
he was all pumped up on the lives of his
government he lived the rest of his life
in pain pain from a broken back pain
from the shrapnel that always reminded
him of these terrible years and pain
from the guilt that he felt
to the russian soldiers listening to
this broadcast you've seen it with your
own eyes
i don't want you to be broken like my
father
arnold also addressed putin himself who
actually follows arnold on twitter
and the people protesting in russia
against him
the dosing power in the kremlin let me
just ask you
why would you sacrifice this young man
for your own ambitions to president
putin i say
you started this war
you're leading this war
you can stop this war to all of the
russians who have been protesting on the
streets against the invasion of ukraine
the world has seen your bravery you have
been arrested you have been jailed and
you have been beaten
you are my new heroes you have the true
heart
of russia
so the big question will it actually
have any impact or will it be ignored
like terminator 3
either way your move sliced alone
so carly um
i thought that was it was i thought it
was pretty impressive
but do you think it'll have any impact
yeah well first of all usually um
celebrity videos during a time of crisis
are not good like the gal gadot imagine
thing this is an exception to the rule i
i thought i thought it was great
to answer your question
that's the problem is that we've been
talking to a lot of anti-putin russians
on fox and friends and and first and
about what russians know you know
what do they know how how do they really
feel about this war and they all say the
same thing that if you are young and you
live in moscow or saint petersburg you
have access to social media
there's a good chance that you know
what's going on but russia is so big and
vast there's a lot of areas where all
you have is state-run tv and so you
you do believe the propaganda so
unfortunately the people that are most
likely to see that video already know
what's going on and it's not going to
reach the folks who it needs to yeah
it's funny rob i talked to uh my wife
elena who is russian sure she is russian
yes she is as far as i know
uh uh but um she thought it was great
she thought it was great she's in poland
right now i asked if it would if it
would move the needle and she sent me a
string of laugh emojis
followed by a capitalized no
and it was like and it was and she's
somebody you know very very very anti
putin and all these but she says but i
think she's basically saying that like
in in russia
you know they don't even have free they
don't have freedom of speech so we we're
thinking right we're thinking that
they're going to react the way we do
also i just say like she probably is
very used to laughing at you and saying
no yeah
just to be fair i'm not taking anything
away from her analysis i walked into
that one and i it felt great by the way
but yeah
but you i mean you don't necessarily
need that i mean the russian revolution
didn't didn't happen because all of the
russian people were in favor of it you
do need a core group of people to agree
so a core can be very effective i mean i
you know look this is a very very great
thing he did so i i it
it pains me to have to make this joke
when he was running for the governor
of california
very effectively he won and people said
hey was your dad a nazi he was like it's
very a confusing time we don't know he
very murky a long time ago and now
suddenly his dad's not only a nazi but
we know he was deployed and like we know
his injuries and everything so like he's
kind of invoking nazi privilege now it's
like hey listen nazi my dad was a nazi
yeah so maybe you should sit this one
out yeah he's like weird okay
but
the more of this the better like if it
is only young people in saint petersburg
in moscow that could be very effective
it's funny if arnold runs for office
again what is he going to praise god oh
no he's not i said i you're not going to
be finished i didn't say nazi nazi yeah
it was important to nazi in springtime
for hitler yeah uh off broadway he's a
trainer stranger doing that yeah yes uh
i know i'm doing terrible impressions
too cat um yes you are um that's true i
don't think putin actually reads his
twitter feed but i don't think so he's
probably really stressed out like
so i don't get it i just don't get the i
don't get why you want to do a war like
it's probably like your life is probably
less stressful before you decided to do
a war and kill a bunch of people and
everybody hate you yes so no he's
probably not looking at twitter i like i
i i don't look at my twitter and i'm
sure the tweets being directed to him
are probably slightly more mean than the
ones directed at me
uh but yeah this video was great yeah
video was good what do you think kennedy
i
i mean
do you think that this is this could
actually have
some impact or it might just be stupid
it has more impact in the united states
it does and he knows that i thought it
was very smart to add the cyrillic so
people even if they don't speak english
they can read along and understand what
he's saying it was incredibly personal
um but you know to carly's point because
she she makes a great point about people
and generations and social media that's
one of the problems with the russian
army is you've got 18 year old
conscripts who are all on tick-tock and
so and and they're seeing information
from their peers they know this is
completely fraudulent and that's why you
know a lot of them are shooting
themselves and giving themselves up do
you think that's true or is that
probably i read those stories i can't
make heads or tales about the the
shooting the desertion and all that
stuff but i don't know what no i think
it's part of that is absolutely true and
if you just look at the timeline and how
long russia has been in ukraine this was
supposed to be like two days a two-day
right jaunt for putin you know to cat's
point like he doesn't he doesn't read
he's like the kamala harris of russia
only in terms of the fact that he
doesn't read his briefing book right
right like that that's where the
similarities end all
wait a right five more minutes on that
because i think you can come up with
some more i think there's a book in
there
[Laughter]
all right well that was interesting hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else